only on CBS this morning senator Martha
McSally is opening up about her painful
past and decision to reveal that she was
raped by a superior officer in the Air
Force the military branch apologized to
the 26-year veteran after she spoke out
during a military sexual assault hearing
on Capitol Hill this week we spoke to
Senator McCauley about why she is
breaking her silence now and her fight
for change like you I am also a military
sexual assault survivor senator martha
mcsalley soared as America's first
female fighter pilot to fly in combat
but face dramatic lows after she says a
superior officer raped her honestly I
didn't even think about reporting it
that's kind of the environment we were
in at the time really yeah why there's a
lot of denial there's a lot of confusion
you kind of you know just suck it up it
wasn't ever communicated necessarily it
just always suck it up I felt like I
didn't have any options at the time you
noted too that you stayed silent for so
long but there was a point in your
military career when you did tell others
in the military and what was their
reaction well let me just say that I
love our Air Force I am proud to have
served in the military I am proud to
have been given the opportunity to break
through glass ceilings for women but
mcsalley says she was disgusted by how
the Air Force handled her case it was
really junior varsity you said it was
worse than that you say she felt like
the system was raping me all over again
interrogating me about what happened to
you tell us what happened to you and I
was mortified if that's the way you are
treating being alerted that somebody
who's been through something like this
who actually is trying to have our
military succeed at dealing with it and
you bring me in and interrogate me as if
I'm the perpetrator even in the tone and
the approach and they're just the
ignorance they failed on the job big
time
I got left and I dropped a bunch of
swear words just to be frank you say you
almost left the military I did
I did I really felt like the system
victimized me again
reports of sexual assaults are up by 50%
at US service academies and nearly 10%
in the military overall assignment Sally
says that more victims may feel
comfortable coming forward do you regret
not reporting the assault I always you
know like to look forward and not back
it's very difficult to put myself back
into the shoes of where I was at the
time so what about a young woman in the
Air Force who may want to make a report
can you say to her right now do it each
person has to make their own decisions
but use the United States Senator I'm
not gonna compel anybody no and you're
on the Armed Services Committee and
you're a former fighter pilot right to
not be able to say yes we will protect
you of course I would want them to
report it of course I would want the
opportunity for immediately there to be
an investigation that they can then
quickly find justice for that victim of
course that's what I want I'm just
saying I'm not gonna tell the victim
what to do just can you say that you
have confidence in the system right now
look we have a lot of work to do we do
we've got to stop the next assault for
happening right now and mcsalley wanted
to be a doctor but set her eyes on the
sky when she was told the Air Force
wouldn't allow female fighter pilots and
it just pissed me off and I said that's
exactly what I'm gonna do and I walked
around saying I'm gonna be the first
woman fighter pilot I knew nothing about
flying but I was mostly driven because
they told me that I couldn't and nothing
not even sexual assault was gonna stop
you from doing that
no way where did that strength come from
to say that the grace of God I really
believe that I think of a scripture and
the Old Testament talks about Joseph he
finally at one point said what others
intended for evil God used for good and
I feel like in my own life some of the
worst experiences I've been through like
sexual assault have actually propelled
me on a positive path that I can fight
for others and that's what my
has been you know she said after all
these experiences she felt more driven
to find a place of power in her life she
said running doing marathons triathlons
helped her do that and I should say we
talked to her office yesterday too she
has received an outpouring of support
phone calls other people calling to
report similar experiences boy it's so
refreshing to see a direct and frank
conversation with a member of the Senate
everybody speaks it Diane also man
that's why you need women in the
military and the Senate to tell these
stories and speak honestly and you know
it's just ask her if the perpetrator is
still there I was very curious about
that I did ask her that and she said she
didn't answer the question
she said that's not where my heart is
I'm not looking for scalps she also said
at one point in the interview that I
didn't have just one occurrence to be
clear so I want to be respectful of her
privacy and her telling that story and
that's the difficulty I think she
embodies the difficulty that all women
have and the military is a microcosm of
society the fear that comes with
reporting it and the retaliation that
you face yeah senator mcsalley put her
in the badass Club yeah it's amazing
that was an amazing interview and what
she had to say since the injury yes that
she felt like she was interrogated and
let's just say and we'll continue to
talk about there's a debate in Congress
about how to fix the system and there
are a lot of differing views about how
to fix that system speaking of so that's
why she brings standing to that debate
it's great work